all right um it's uh just about 9:15 I'm
going to call the uh Judiciary Committee
uh executive session to order and I'm
first going to recognize representative
allegiance to the flag of the United
States of America to the rep stands one
nation under God indivisible with liy
all so uh before we get started I just
wanted to just um uh a couple of sort of
housekeeping matters just for the
members of the committee to know um I uh
I know that there have been that there
have been some uh there expressions of
angst and I I appreciate that about the
fact that I have started all the
hearings that I've scheduled and I've
now scheduled out through February 21st
so that we have all the bills scheduled
for hearings I've scheduled those all at
9:00 um and I know that that has created
some angst for some people uh but I I
think in order to the the speaker really
wants us to get things so that they get
to the they can get sessions so I think
I'm probably am going to keep that in
place but I have I have heard you and
part particularly since for hearings we
don't need to have a quorum if some of
you you know straggle in a little bit
late I'm not going to be keeping tabs on
what time you show up but I will say
that other than next Monday which I've
already scheduled for any fur any future
executive sessions I will schedule those
to start at 10:00 um so that you know it
give that because there that's where we
do need a quorum um uh so I I will uh I
will do that um I just wanted to I just
wanted to um let everybody know that um
and then with that um I think we're
ready to turn to uh the business of of
the executive uh session and so I'm
first going to uh uh take up cacr 23 and
I will represent recognize
representative kab for a
motion I move itl is there a second
second it's been moved in seconded
representative kav do wish to speak to
your
motion so I think the majority of New
Hampshire has spoken that they would
like the law to stay as it is today
and it is my hope that in the future we
can come to a compromise on some
language of a cacr that would keep the
law as it is today however the problem
with what we have before us is that it's
not a cacr that just gives the right to
abortion prior to 24 weeks but a
cacr that gives the right to abortion if
it's necessary after that for any reason
right through birth and necessary can
mean multiple things it is not defined
as medically necessary so it can be
necessary simply because somebody wants
to have one and that is not what the
majority of Voters have spoken on this
bill alone I have gotten the most
emails on any bill I have ever received
asking to please itl this so I think
even if this were to go to the voters it
is not what the majority of the voters
want either and so with that I think it
should be
itl other people wish to be
heard
yes representative
chair um as as a life
supporting person in my personal ethical
and religious
beliefs um I hold that uh life begins at
conception and it's sacred from the
moment of conception to the moment of
natural
death
Article 2 part one of our New Hampshire
Constitution protects
respects life as part of our traditional
values this uh cacr
23 um is counter and contrary to those
traditions and
beliefs and um I think that even if it
were to pass there would be some
constitutional problems with
it um I think it's improper and wronge
headed and therefore I'm voting itl on
it other comments other people wish to
be heard all right so I guess the only
thing I would say on this I'm sorry did
you want to say something the only thing
I would say on this is um I think I I
have a at least a somewhat nuanced
position from representative k
I'm as I've told people many many times
I reg if somebody asked me what my views
are on abortion I would say generally
I'm pro-choice um but I do believe that
there that that shouldn't mean that
somebody has a right to an abortion up
to very close to the time to birth and I
I agree with representative katab that I
think most people in New Hampshire think
our current law which basically says you
have six months if you're pregnant you
have six months to make a decision as to
what whether or not you want to have an
abortion is a reasonable period of time
and after that um I I think it's hard to
argue that whatever your views are on
sort of you know life uh and when it
begins or it's it it does seem to me
that it's hard to argue that there is
not an increasing interest of society in
in the
protection of of uh the fetus or the
child or whatever you want to call it
that that interest interest increases as
time goes on and at some point I mean if
it if it doesn't then why is it why
wouldn't it just be okay you know I
suppose in some you know ghoulish kind
of way we could say we're going to treat
uh we're going to treat a a child as uh
like a consumer product and Ju Just like
when uh in some consumer transactions
you have three days to cancel I suppose
if we want to be really ghoulish we
could say well you should have three
days after birth to decide if the if
want to cancel the transaction hopefully
we we never get to that point but it
seems to me that that um what what we
have in law now of six months is a
reasonable period that I believe most
people in the state of New Hampshire
share I would not support frankly
imposing making the the Restriction any
greater than that I know there's been
some talk of reducing it uh somewhat uh
because viability maybe or maybe in the
future
would uh would be would be at less than
24 weeks
um it's hard to say never but I think it
would take a lot to convince me
personally that that it would be
appropriate to do that um having said
that I I the area where I think I
disagree with with representative kutab
to some extent is I just don't think
this is something that ought to be in
the Constitution um although I regard
myself as I said as pro-choice I think
the Supreme Court made absolutely the
right decision in DOS in overruling Ro v
Wade because that was essentially the
that was in an era roow was decided in
an era where the Supreme Court thought
it was really okay to kind of create new
rights uh because nine people or in that
case seven people uh on the court
thought now this is a great idea let's
create this new right um and I just
fortunately the court uh now um has a
different view on its Authority in this
area area and um I think it made the
absolutely the correct decision in in in
uh dobs and now returned it to the
states where it seems to me it should be
something that is decided by uh through
the political process as as almost
everything uh that that we deal with uh
is decided through the political process
I I think that the public has made it
pretty clear um where they stand and uh
I think that that
our law is now consistent with that so
for that reason I'm going to support the
itl any any other comments All right so
I guess we're then we're ready to uh
role Vice chairman Wallace yes re
Alexander yes re Andrews yes re
testerman yes re Stapleton yes rep trip
yes rep gon yes Clerk have votes yes rep
Perez yes rep
Smith rep Brennan no rep De Lorenzo no
rep Kenny no rep pige no rep
Divine no rep lonza no rep Manos no rep
turer no rep Ming no chairman Lynn yes
motion bails 10 to
10 all right
um uh representative chair recognized
representative
Smith thank you very much um Mr chair um
cr23 and would like to speak to my
motion when you consider it appropriate
is there a second
representative Terror seconds the motion
uh yes represent actually who seconded I
I I meant to ask you who seconded
representative ter I believe second no
on the previous motion I was okay thank
you very much I neglected to write
that
um I found my colleagues comments quite
interesting um and uh respect their
their right certainly to express the
comments I do not
agree um I support this Constitutional
Amendment that would
enshrine Reproductive Rights in the
Hampshire's state
constitution when I first entered the
legislature which was
overwhelmingly
Republican and I never found that to be
a problem for all the years until quite
shockingly for the first time in history
since Adam and Eve almost um the
Democrats were in the
majority certain things changed but a
lot of things didn't what was consistent
always and I believe at some level is
still here is that in New Hampshire we
respect privacy and and what was a
classic libertarian attitude but not
one sometimes definitions change but was
that the state should stay out
of private rights the state should say
stay out and that was something that
everybody overwhelmingly Republican in
the
legislature but somewhat increasingly
mixed in terms of the public
because a political party felt the same
way um and we were quite comfortable
with that then over the years things
changed what changed um when the Supreme
Court uh uh overturned uh
row um was that the Supreme Court stated
as clearly as
possible that these decisions should be
made not at the federal level but at the
state level that is what the decision St
it is up to the states to
decide in this body with 400
people people from other states laugh
when we have a total population of 1.3
million how do you have a legislature of
400 each one of us rep representing a
little over 3,000 people and the answer
is it is the best way that we could stay
close as we choose in this state to a
direct democracy not a representative
democracy but a
direct uh and that's why when we go into
the grocery store We're stopped by our
neighbors because they know who we are
doesn't happen in other states um in a
direct uh
democracy it is the
people who make decisions on important
issues and that has always been the way
we have done it in this state and it is
a way that I respect let the people
decide it is important that we don't
take this lightly and that it's not a
frivolous act on our part which is why
we require
60% of the legislature a super majority
60% of the legislature to vote on a
constitutional amendment so we're not
just forgetting our responsibility as
legislators and sending everything out
it is equally true that it is important
to recognize the the incredible
significance of amending the
Constitution and that is why for the
citizens it requires not 60% but 66 and
23% something that is very hard to
achieve and increasingly hard in an
environment which has pits people
against each other I don't object to the
66 and 2/3 I think if two out of three
voters think the the Constitutional
Amendment the Constitution should change
so be it and I think if one is it fewer
or less I always get confused if there's
one vote short on the 66 and
23 and and and cons Amendment doesn't
pass that's okay too but we have gone to
the people and asked them how do you
think about this issue which affects
everybody every family in their most
private decisions and it is therefore by
very strongly held view that that this
body has an obligation to the citizens
of the state to vote on this and if we
can get a majority in this committee
wonderful if we can get a 60% majority
in the floor wonderful each of those
votes takes us closest to the people
where we are asking them to decide on
something that could not be more of a
private personal decision than this and
therefore I ask you all to support um
the OTP
motion anyone else wish to be
representative
tur yeah I I just wanted to add to those
comments uh in turn and and and somewhat
respond to to what was um said um by Mr
chair on the on the last vote um making
the distinction between uh a
constitutional right first is a law in
the books and I feel that it's important
for this point to focus on uh the idea
of Rights being things that are you know
inherent and and uh deeply personal and
basically things that we as the
legislature should not you know be in
involved in and you know I think our
reproduction our our choices about our
our reproduction um really constitute
you know in terms of the concept of
freedom fre and Liberty over our bodies
some of the most deeply held and
personal um choices that people make in
in their lives and
uh the reason that it should I think be
in our constitution is to restore what
most people have come to expect over the
course of their lives um as a what had
been a consensus that basically these
are areas where at least up to you know
the levels that are are embodied in this
cacr um the legislature doesn't have a
role um and and our personal choices you
know extending beyond the the end of our
Our Lives um you know at 24 weeks the
the statement you know natural death you
know right now natural extension of of
life is is highly supported by
technology at that at that age um of of
development so
I just I just wanted to make the
distinction for for you know the the the
discussion between why we would have a
constitutional amendment to him trying
to write that keeps us out of people's
lives versus a law that can change
rapidly back and forth and really cause
you know a lot of consternation uh the
bills that we'll hear shortly you know
also generated a lot of input um uh and
and caused a lot of of uh
anxiety for people in terms of our our
state so that's all other yes
chair it was brought up that the state
should not be involved in these very
personal matters and yet in this
Constitutional Amendment the wording
says the state cannot prohibit restrict
delay or penalize this right prior to 24
weeks unless it is justified by a comp
compelling State interest achieved by
the least restrictive means so this
Constitutional Amendment still allows
the state to stick its nose in other
people's business so what is a
compelling State
interest if the state has no
interest if the state is to keep its
nose out of it then then this is a
fatally flawed Constitutional Amendment
right
here other
comments yes representative
Perez when I was
campaigning I would say 90% of the
people that asked me about our abortion
law had no
idea what our abortion law was here in
the state of New Hampshire and I would
say of that 90% at least 70% were
shocked that it was 24
weeks my constituents that I have heard
it wanted less they elected us to make
informed decisions for them because they
cannot know everything that is going
on and I think I was elected to make
informed decisions I think if you put
this
out to the
public you're not going to have informed
decisions people may go for it or they
may not go but I'm going to say it's not
going to be an informed decision
and therefore I think it's the right and
the obligation of those of us that are
elected to make these
informed decisions for our
constituents other other comments yes
representative L please um I just want
to say first of all when we do get
testimony we only get a certain
percentage of testimony we're not
hearing from all of our voters out there
so number one I think we really need to
think think about um how important it is
that we place this on the ballot and to
become a constit constitutional
amendment because I think the we need to
hear from all of the voters out there um
that have not been represented and have
not been heard from I think all women
need to have the right to um get the the
care that they need and this is so very
important um so I think that was lady
say we need to consider this it's what
we're getting is the testimonies that we
get from um voters out there are only a
certain percentage and we really need to
think about that as we make our
decisions and I just want to thank you
for letting me speak thank you other
comments uh yes representative Staples
please thank you Mr
chair my emails are running somewhere
around 25 5
to1 opposed to cacr
23 and so many of the comments um have
indicated that uh 24 weeks is reasonable
one even said well that's about
right so it does reflect a lot of
variability
in uh the
constituency support or opposition to
abortion but yet they've come and told
us that um this is over the line um and
we shouldn't be making this a matter of
constitution talking about
Constitution dobs had two important
points and of course the one that's
stressed more important most importantly
in in media and culture today is uh it's
a state's rights well that's very
important but the other important point
which was foremost
dob said the Constitution affords no
constitutional right for an
abortion and if that's the case because
we have the right to life liberty and
property in the
Constitution uh abortion in a
constitutional amend would be
contraindicated against the right to
life as far as laws well we had 52 years
a permissive a liberty uh in law was
contrary
to the
Constitution um as as dos points out um
was an error in affording a right that
is not guaranteed or provided for in the
Constitution so laws should comply with
what we have in Constitution the feds
were sending us a message yes you states
can go and deal with this issue as is
appropriate for states
rights but be
advised that there is no right to
abortion in the
Constitution what they were doing is
reinforcing the importance of Life the
state interest to see life um be
developed and then born into
citizenry and so they're they're
pointing us to the direction that we
should consider this very very
carefully and not even come close to
violating not respecting life not only
born life and adult life but also nass
womb so I I'm I'm I'm opposed to the uh
OTP on on cacr
23 repres CH yeah just just one more
Point since we had we drifted into sort
of the the the balance of the input that
we got through our testimony and through
our emails um I just wanted to lift up
that we also have the sign-ins online um
which represents a larger group of
people than any of those others and and
um the the sign-ins from this bill were
1,713 in support um 303 opposed and one
neutral so you know there there was a
fairly overwhelming in uh level of
support for people who took the time to
sign into our committee
thanks other comments um the only the
only the only other thing I would say I
to that because I think representative
gon raised an important Point as I in
some of the questions that I asked
during the hearing I
I even if I try to put myself in the in
the in the shoes of the supporters of
this amendment I really do think that
from your I would think that from your
perspective there are some problems with
this amendment as I indicated before
first of all the the the first line
every individual has a fundamental right
to abortion well it seems to me if this
were actually to pass you would for sure
have a father saying wait a minute um I
have the right if if if uh the the woman
that I've impregnated wants uh wants to
have baby and I don't want her to have
the baby I have some right uh under this
proposed constitutional amendment to
insist that she have an abortion because
every individual not just the pregnant
person has a fundamental right at least
that would be an argument and if you
really I assume that the people who are
supporting this didn't intend that so
why not say if you're if it's not you
know politically correct from your point
of view to say only women can get
pregnant um why not say uh every
pregnant person has the right to an
abortion instead of every individual I I
don't quite understand it from your
perspective the second thing that I
don't understand is as I understand the
law the law right
now up to 24 weeks a woman has the right
to have an abortion for any reason or no
reason doesn't have to give a reason um
and there's no sort of balancing does
the state have some compelling interest
to prevent her under the law from having
an abortion if this Constitutional
Amendment were adopted it would seem to
suggest that um that imposes some kind
of or at least could impose some kind of
additional restriction uh that the state
could come along and say well it's under
24 weeks but there's some I don't know
some reason that uh is a constitutes a
compelling interest that the state
should be able to
intervene I again I guess I don't
understand um why you would word things
this way even from your perspective uh
representative Smith thank you um Mr
chair and thank you for your comments um
I know that nothing that has been said
since this discussion
began has changed let me reward that I
would think it highly
unlikely that anything that has been
said um has changed the views of the 20
people on this committee who have to
make a decision now knowing that there
will be countless opportunities in the
future to further debate and therefore
other than having people feel good about
saying what they're saying I would like
to move the
question all right seeing no further
discussion I think it's time to call the
role the motion before us is is on ought
to pass on cacr
223 Vice chairman Wallace No rep
Alexander no rep Andrews no rep
testerman no rep Stapleton no rep trip
no I'm learning how to
choose rep gson
no cler cab votes no rep Perez
no rep
Smith rep Brennan yes rep dorenzo
yes rep Kenny yes rep paage yes rep
Divine yes rep lonza yes rep Manos yes
repur yes rep Ming yes chairman Lynn no
motion fails 10 to
um rep kab will you write the uh report
and if you'd like some assistance in
that I'm happy to help um and we who
will write the report on I will write
the report Mr chair of ought to pass um
you well well no OTP will be under I
think there will be I mean it will be
without recommendation but OT the OTP
motion will go
first um the OTP motion Mr chair
will go first and that means that the
first person to speak um would be uh a
person to speak against the
OTP motion and then uh the people in
favor get to speak and um uh following
what we have tried to do all along is
um
concentrate
our comments um so that we have as few
people as possible speaking on each each
side um so that people feel the pressure
to be cogent and
focused and um I would hope that we
continue that here and that we don't end
up with uh long and painful debate that
won't accomplish anything no I I agree
with you there I I definitely agree with
you there and as I understand it since
this require this has to be a uh uh at
least a division vote and maybe I assume
it'll be a roll call but it has to be at
least a division because we need 60% and
I assume that right if it fa if if if
the OTP fails I assume that's really the
end of it then if the OTP fails that is
in fact the end of it the end of it
right that's what I thought okay all
right um all right then next I'm going
to turn to um House Bill 1248 and I
recognize representative Tura for a
motion
wait what 1248 that's the uh 15 day no
the 15 day is representative I'm sorry
rep I've got it backward then represent
I recognize representative Manos for a
motion thank you Mr chair I move itl on
HB
1248 in my mind this is there can I just
interrupt one second is there a
second representative Paige seconds all
right yes uh representative Mount thank
you Mr chair in my mind this 15-day ban
on abortions is
Draconian most women don't know they're
pregnant within 15 days uh uh pregnancy
tests are not reliable at 15 days of
pregnancy this amounts to outlawing
abortion in New Hampshire forcing women
to go out of state and delaying
necessary and needed care this is not
what the people of New Hampshire want
and I move itl on
1248 right anyone else wish to be heard
on yes representative
testr 15 days is in fact
unreasonable there should not be
allowance for an abortion at all I just
picked 15 days to to show where you know
we we might get
uh abortion is is in fact a
mistake uh it's a taking of a life uh
and that's
wrong anyone else wish to be
heard all right I've seeing none I guess
we're ready to call the role uh it's the
motion is itl on uh House Bill
1248 Vice chairman Wallace yes rep
Alexander yes rep Andrews yes rep
testerman yes rep Stapleton
yes rep trip yes rep gon yes clerk kab
votes yes rep Perez yes rep Smith yes
Lorenzo
yes rep Kenny yes rep Paige yes rep
Divine
yes rep Lanza yes yes rep Manos yes
repur yes rep Ming yes chairman Lynn
yes Mo motion passes 20 to zero sorry I
I I'd like to check on something did I
vote no to begin you voted you voted yes
I I meant to say
no all
right okay so motion passes 19 to one um
Can this go on consent anybody object to
it going on consent I'll object to it
going on
consent okay all right so it will not be
on consent all right all right um and
who is uh who is uh shall we
representative M you write the report
all right will there be a Minority
Report representative
testman I'll put one in all right
representative testman
um Mr chair may I just inquire when you
want the report oh yes yes you know what
um can I have it by the end of the day
today um I know it's h you know that we
really want it's not going to make it on
the thing for the next uh uh well I
don't think there is going to be one
next THS is there not enough bills yet
yeah so uh i' I'd appreciate if you get
you
will
say
all right um turn to uh House Bill U
1541 and uh chair recognized
representative tur for a
motion thank you Mr chairman I'd like to
make the motion to itl HB 1541 all right
is there second I second
oh all
right seconded by representative Andrew
I second the motion all right
um uh representative TR would you like
to speak to your motion yeah uh this
bill has uh uh a large number of um
inconsistent and inaccurate and
conflicting um uh components to it it it
brings in terms that are not medically
sound um brings in practices that are
not medically um Justified um um
conflates the the concepts of of
viability with the time limit that's set
and uh I think in general goes against
the consensus of what the people of New
Hampshire um expect for uh this um
component of their their reproductive
choice right anyone else wish to speak
on uh HP 1541 yes representative Greece
thank you Mr
chair throughout the discussion on the
debate on this bill
and even comments that I have heard
there have been some misconceptions
about what this bill actually proposes
it is not actually there's no there's
absolutely no restrictions on abortion
whatsoever it's not reducing it down to
15 weeks from 24 weeks down to 15 weeks
that that is not in this bill at all it
just says that a second physician would
be in attendance to care for the baby if
the baby should be born alive during the
performance of an abortion now as
represent resentative Smith pointed out
no one's opinions are going to be
changed by anything said here today but
just wanted to point out that this bill
does not restrict abortions to 15 weeks
the second thing I wanted to point out
is when we use the term viability with
relation to abortion it is a very
specious
argument because a baby a human baby is
not supposed to be viable outside the
womb at 15 weeks or 24 weeks in fact the
normal gational period for a human baby
is 40 weeks I confirm that with women
who have been pregnant so speaking as a
man and ignorant of biology um it's 40
weeks according to to
women so if the fact that at barely
onethird of the way through normal
gestation it's not able to survive
outside the womb is a no-brainer it's
not intended to or even
halfway it's not intended to the fact
that sometimes babies are born at 24
weeks and they survive is just a
miracle so when we use the term
viability you're using a word that
actually means absolutely nothing
because it's not intended to live
outside the safety of the womb until it
is fully developed and ready for natural
birth or cesarian however you want to
come out that's all I got to say about
that but just so you know when you use
the word
viability you are you you you are not
using uh a word that means
anything right anyone else um wish to
speak to uh HB
1541 okay I'll just leave it up to uh
what was just
said it's it's a pretty pretty common
answer on viability it's not thank you
all right all right any anyone else wish
to be heard all right seeing none I
think we're ready for the roll call on
uh the itl motion on hb1
1541 Vice chairman Wallace yes rep
Alexander yes rep Andrew yes rep
testerman no rep Stapleton yes rep trip
yes rep gon yes clerk could tab votes
yes rep Perez yes rep
Smith
yes rep Brennan yes rep dorenzo yes rep
Kenny yes rep Paige yes rep
Divine
yes rep lonza
yes rep Manos
yes chairman Lynn yes
motion passes 19 to1 and this go on
consent anyone object to it being on
consent all right this will be on
consent
um and represent be doing
majority represent you'll you'll write
the blurb uh for the majority for for
okay that would be the report the report
right all right and will there be a
minority report
represent yes sir will all right all
right um well yeah I think yeah I think
there might be so all right so um let me
just uh review uh so that
everybody everybody's clear um on on cic
R23 um representative katab will write
the report uh for those favoring itl
representative Smith will write the
report for those faor favoring um OTP uh
on 1248 representative Manos will write
the majority report of itl and
representative testerman will write the
uh Minority Report of uh
OTP and on
1248 I'm sorry 1541 uh representative CH
will write the majority report of uh itl
and representative testerman will write
a Minority Report of uh OTP and again
I'd appreciate if I could have all those
reports in by the end of the day today
all right um may I ask a question yes
sir can I ask why we couldn't put 1248
on consent I mean it the it came out 19
to1 and it's it when in favor of
the I mean I it
just of your motion that was
seconded I I just don't know if it's
chair the member does not have to reason
I think that's the right the member okay
that's fine that's fine I apologize
I
somebody yes representative
test
right oh okay so do you want it off
consent then Mr representative testman
do you want I'm sorry you want it I mean
it okay all right so it'll stay on
consent and there will not be a Minority
Report all right on on uh on 1541 on
on on 12:48 though you will write a
Minority Report on that is that
great no it's not 124 1248 is not on
consent um oh but 15 41 is on consent
all right I think right next
good jez convinced me to vote with her
on
that almost right right right close but
no cigar
yes I ask you this but I write it down
last time we had um i' ask you for if
you could make a recommendation
trust attorney I believe there was a g
that testified here I don't know if
she's you would
recomend I don't need an answer today no
I I would I don't I'm trying to remember
her name got to do the Elder planning
station